(audience applauding)
Coming to you from the
historic Largo theater
in Hollywood,
it's Conan.
I'm Andy Richter.
Tonight, Jane Lynch.
And now here is, Conan O'Brien
Thank you.
(clapping)
Thank you very much.
Welcome to tonight show, Jane Lynch.
Love her, is gonna be joining us,
and let me begin by saying
we are celebrating Christmas
tonight on the Conan show.
That's right.
Why you ask, are we celebrating Christmas?
Because we thought it over
and the way things are going,
it looks like we might not
make it to December 25th.
And I love Christmas,
and I want to get my Christmas this year.
I just don't trust that it's gonna happen.
You know, every year,
Andy, what do you think?
Isn't this the way to go?
Yep.
Might as well.
Yeah.
Remember how you've always
made fun of me. You were like,
"Why do you keep that elf suit
in the trunk of your car all the time?
Paid off.
You know what, you're right.
Gotta admit.
I didn't think you needed
it in your trunk of your car
all the time, but Andy,
it came in real handy.
As you can see,
all our cardboard cutouts
are in the Christmas spirit.
All of them, that took us
that took us three hours,
and for some reason, $600,000
(laughing)
to put the hats on those.
Yeah
I suspect some sort of
union shenanigans but,
No
I'm not asking any questions.
This is my hat company's first order.
(laughing)
Well, congratulations, Andy.
That's right tonight,
our show is a Christmas show
because I just don't think
we're going to make it,
to the actual day, December 25th.
Let's get it in now.
And of course,
no holiday celebration is
complete without a little
Christmas music.
That's right.
I've thought of everything.
Here to provide that for us
Please welcome the Los
Angeles mass children's choir.
♪ Jingle bells, jingle bells, ♪
♪ jingle all the way. ♪
♪ Oh, what fun it is to ride ♪
♪ in a one-horse open sleigh, hey. ♪
♪ Jingle bells, jingle bells ♪
♪ jingle all the way, ♪
♪ Oh, what fun it is to ride ♪
♪ In a one-horse open sleigh, hey ♪
And just so you all know,
I too I'm being careful.
I've got my Christmas mask right here.
These are gonna be big this year.
Isn't that great.
I love this.
These are gonna sell like hotcakes.
What do you think, Andy?
I think you're gonna make kids cry.
You think it's scary?
Yeah it's kinda like you're eating Santa.
No,
I'm vomiting up a Santa,
I ate two hours ago.
Well, once you tell the
kids that that'll be fine.
Yeah.
Anyway, let's check back in
with Los Angeles mass children's choir.
♪ Silent night, holy night ♪
♪ All is calm, all is bright ♪
♪ (indistinct singing) ♪
Man, those kids have a lot of heart.
They do.
They sound like shit.
(laughing)
But they've got a lot of heart.
Merry Christmas kids.
Yeah.
Just hoping you didn't
stay up to watch the show.
Hey, let's check back
in with those wonderful
Los Angeles mass children's choir.
(indistinct singing)
It's the masks kids.
It's not you,
although there were two
of you that I think,
well, anyway, let it go.